hey youtubers it's Charlie so this is
gonna be my Q&A for arrow and the flash
this week is you know DC related stuff
thank you everyone that submitted
questions there were actually like a lot
of comic book things that happen in the
flash episode in a couple really big
twist that we need to talk about from
arrow a lot of you asked about the CW
fan talk to I don't know if they're
going to upload the video anywhere it
seemed like everyone in international
countries had trouble watching it so
I'll see if there's any workarounds if I
ever do something like that again so
let's get to some arrow flash craziness
just general spoiler warning from
episodes ten of the flash and arrow if
you haven't seen them yet so here we go
question number one Deadpool pie that's
an awesome name throat gets crushed
stabbed in stomach stabbed in chest
probably through a lung kicked off a
cliff and left in the freezing cold for
days brought back almost instantly
thanks to MacGuffin plot device all hail
mighty MacGuffin plots of ice so that's
actually a really good statement I think
that they'll answer how they brought him
back in the next episode or two I mean
we'll find out really quickly but i
think the real big question is going to
be what is he going to do now that he's
back and just explain the falling off
the cliff thing and a lot of people were
wondering why didn't every bone in his
body smash Stephen Amell implied in a
couple interviews that maybe something
broke his fall and we just we just
didn't see it like they just the way
they cut it so just assume he fell hard
enough to knock him out cold and leave
him near the point of death but not so
hard that every bone in his body was
smashed to dust question number two lots
more Olly stuff so akba asks I'm glad
they just flat out tell you all he's not
dead we all know he's not going to die
so why pretend it's even a mystery
seeing how he recovers and get back to
Starling is far more interesting yeah so
if you remember the episode that he had
with katana they talked a lot about
what's going on up top like a very
meditative exploration of his psyche so
I think we'll get a lot of that Messiah
said that he asked katana to come to
wherever it is that they are to bring
him back to life the way they cut the
episode makes it seem like they're
moving in real time so you know whatever
three days it's been they could have
jumped around a time a little bit so we
don't know how long he was out cold what
I'm really hoping is is they explain it
in some weight so that he gets to
actually be dead for that period of time
that he was out it'll be really
interesting to see like what's going on
up up in his head like if he and katana
do some crazy meditation like they did
in the previous episode on to
question number three so k 2002 ish asks
i think Merlin will die this season
saving thean or Oliver or somebody like
that and when Merlin dies Oliver will
tell people to start calling him green
arrow because Merlin suggested calling
him in that in season one that's
actually a good thought I don't know if
they're gonna kill Merlin off this soon
I mean John Barrowman feels like one of
the anchors of the show I mean he's a
really big character it is interesting
to think about when he's gonna start
calling himself green arrow sidestep to
Laurel shes black canary like the
writers have said she's not the canary
shes black canary so if she's getting
the full name maybe oliver full name is
right around the corner maybe part of
this death and resurrection process is
upgrading himself to green arrow from
just the arrow back to life with a brand
new personality what I'd really like to
see is them hold off on green arrow the
green arrow name until right before the
series finale and then like in the
series finale they let Batman come on
the show and induct him into the Justice
League question number 4 Stephen Foster
asks i wonder if arrow is going to bring
on the old arrow I'm talking about alan
tudyk from injustice gods among us so
it's totally possible you could see
other people from the DC Universe or
previous versions of the DC Universe
popping up on arrow it's just a question
of budget like it costs a lot of money
to get the sector's on the show and
schedules have to line up i think i was
saying during my arrow review that the
Ted grant character the actor playing
him got cast on another show someone had
asked Marc Guggenheim if Black Canary
was going to have a romance with him
this year and he said that was the plan
but because the actor got cast on
another show then it was a no-go they
probably weren't going to do it so most
of the time bringing actors on the show
and trying to use them a lot just
doesn't work out for a variety of
reasons mark hamill on the flash is
actually an example of it working though
when it works really well he's going to
be playing the older version of the
trickster like his character from the
original flash TV series I'll talk more
about that whenever we get to that
episode it's like several several weeks
away question number five Jack DeCarlo
asks hey Charlie which Robin do you
think would most likely be on arrow the
flash personally I think it would be Tim
Drake because they already have Captain
Boomerang who killed Tim's father I
totally agree with your logic I just I
feel like DC and Warner Brothers
wouldn't let them do Batman characters
that big the writers have said a couple
times that they're just flat-out not
allowed to reference Gotham's
or metropolis like there's certain
places that are just off limits so a lot
of Batman characters they can't use but
they did get to use racial ghoul so it's
always possible part of the problem is
is that they're starting a Teen Titans
live-action series it means just called
Titans it's going to have Nightwing so
that Robin is obviously going to be off
limits because of that they also might
make all the other Robins off-limits
Gotham is supposedly going to be doing
the Graysons but it'll be doing the
flying Grayson's so if you want to see
any Robins the closest you'll probably
get as far as we know now is Gotham
question number 6 Jeffrey Gibson s what
do you think the chances are that
Malcolm Merlyn will team up with team
arrow I can't remember if the producer
said it so I don't want to make any big
theories about them teaming up I do
vaguely recall them talking about
Malcolm Merlyn fighting with Oliver not
necessarily in like a regular team up
but them versus ratio goal type
situation because right now rashad goal
still wants Merlin and he just killed
Oliver so they still have to resolve
that plot episode 15 is called Nanda
Parbat so something big is probably
going to be happening inside danda
Parbat there was this interesting
interview that John Barrowman did where
he talked about Merlin's character this
season and how he views himself like he
views himself as the protagonist like
any vain character would they'd always
be the center of their own story but he
kind of came off is if he was describing
Merlin as viewing himself as a good
character trying to do some good things
I don't know if that will amount to
atonement or anything like that but that
could lead to him fighting off rachele
goal with Oliver that's just one of many
possibilities but i'll post the link to
that john barrowman interview he talks a
lot about Merlin question number 7 so
we're actually we're mostly getting to
flash questions now Rhonda flash stuff
nadeem asks will they show mirror master
yeah I definitely think they will I mean
they have most of the core rogues
already either they've already cast them
or we've already seen them on screen I
think part of the reason they might be
holding off on mirror master is because
of the way his powers work like they
want to show the flash phasing through
objects before they have other
characters do it it's like they're
slowly ramping up the craziness in terms
of powers there's no way they're going
to get to every single rogue from the
comics so season 2 you'll probably see
some rogue characters that you did not
see in season 1 Greg gustan was actually
think that time travel could actually
really alter season 2 but I think that'd
be more of a flashpoint situation where
the reverse-flash does something crazy
in the finale this season and then the
flash has to fix it in season two that's
just him speculating they haven't even
started working on season two yet arrow
just started breaking the story for
episode 20 I think the flash is like a
little bit ahead of them but they'll
both have 23 episodes in the season so
both of them haven't even started
writing their finales yet question
number 8 Jose you have a bowl as a
super-fast Barry couldn't just take the
guns from them doesn't he see everything
in slow mo this episode was so dumb okay
well like I said I mean it doesn't
follow real-world logic really when
you're thinking about why characters do
things one either they're trying to
replicate like a panel from the comics
in this case they were it was actually
this panel right here they were trying
to duplicate this from the comics it was
just done for dramatic effect Stephen
Amell has talked about this issue on
arrow like you know with the way they do
things he said their number one goal is
to make interesting TV sometimes that
means bending the rules of logic
question number 9 Scott and asks it
blows me away how there are all these
possible splinter shows all of a sudden
considering how surprisingly good the
first two are you talking about air on
the flash it does feel a little odd
though with green arrow being a league
level character flash top tier all the
rest of the shows are doing generally
seem focused on second and third-string
characters it kind of makes the flash
seem a little lopsided either way the
more the merrier so yeah you're just
you're saying how like the other comic
book shows don't have quite as many
a-list characters they actually will we
have the Supergirl show coming they just
announced Melissa been eos is going to
play Kara zor-el and then they have Teen
Titans Nightwing I guess you could look
at night wing is like a green arrow
level character at some point there will
be so so many characters on television
that yeah some of them will have more
power than the others I know a lot of
people are actually wondering about
about those shows I will be doing videos
for those shows whenever they come I
might do some super girl videos in the
in the near future just because they
cast the lead they're finishing the
pilot they have like a serious
commitment so we will get episodes even
if they do end up canceling it or if it
does great regardless it's like a Gotham
situation with Supergirl whenever they
were conceiving Gotham like whenever
they were making that show Fox ordered a
certain amount of episodes up front even
before they saw the pilot it
kind of the same deal at CBS I mean it's
not exactly the same fingers crossed
that they finish the pilot by comic-con
so they might air the pilot at comic-con
for Supergirl question number ten Carlos
Farina s do you think that the
reverse-flash really wants the flash to
achieve super speed to somehow travel to
his own time well he has the device now
so presumably he doesn't need Grant
Gustin to travel through time so
Harrison wells actually seems like he
genuinely likes Barry Allen like he
doesn't secretly hate him in the comics
a bard Thawne actually admired Barry
Allen is the flash before he became
professor zoom what ended up happening
is is that he traveled back to Barry
Allen's time but kind of missed the mark
went to the flash Museum then found out
that he was destined to become the
reverse-flash and it drove him crazy so
I'm wondering if yes Harrison wells is a
0 bars on admires Barry Allen in the
future so comes back in time to help him
fix the future which another reverse
flash has messed up if anyone's gonna do
any messing up of any time lines I think
it'll be Eddie thawne's reverse-flash
whenever or however he gets powers
they're really mixing and matching
storylines from wally west Sarah and
Barry Allen's era Harrison wells keeps
staring at that paper and I think he
keeps looking to see if the headlines
change I think he wants to fix the
future or at least achieve some specific
outcome and he wants buried to be able
to fight whatever that crisis is
question number 11 al Renshaw asks do
you think that the friend who's secretly
funding project firestorm that jason
rusch didn't know about is dr. wells so
i do think that Harrison wells had
something to do with it but he said the
military came and took all their
equipment the next day jason rusch said
so i think it also could have been
Clancy Browns character if you remember
he was obsessed with metahumans and he
had worked with Harrison wells
previously so of the two people it could
be you know either Harrison wells doing
something a little more sinister or
general Eiling question number 12 get
off your ass do you think that the
Rogues will gain powers like in the new
52 comics or just stay with weapons well
well some of them it's like a half an
half situation some of them have the
guns some of them have like the the
weapons and some of them have full-blown
powers like if you remember weather
wizard from episode one obviously his
brother is going to become the new
weather wizard but he had metahuman
powers I think for now they're going to
go with the classic versions of the
characters although I do think that will
see more metahuman rogues show up
especially in season two question number
thirteen raz mws I do enjoy the flash
even though I admit it's cheesy but this
episode was very very cheesy it have
girl in distress cliche really so you're
talking about Caitlin snow getting
captured like damsel in distress stuff
yes I think we'll see less of that in
the future I think caitlin snow will be
a lot more capable I think it was all by
design just so that they could get the
Rogues versus the flash moment at the
end of the episode air is a good example
of where I think they're going to get to
like Caitlin will get to felicity
territory where like yeah she might not
be the strongest character in the world
but she's very smart fair resourceful so
she'll get herself out of jams in the
future you'll just see more damsels so
to speak saving themselves question
number fourteen traceur asks is it true
that the flash won't get faster because
there's two flashes siphoning the Speed
Force so that's true in the comics I
mean they talked about that during flash
point during that movie too if you saw
the animated movie I don't know if the
show is gonna address that I hope they
do I think we're a couple steps away
from that I think Barry Allen first test
to learn who Harrison wells really is
that he's the reverse-flash and then at
some point Harrison wells will explain
to Barry Allen you know what the Speed
Force is how it works a much broader
explanation of how his powers work and
what he's capable of in more along those
lines the flash will be time-traveling
this season this is the first time that
he does will be completely by accident
it'll be because something that the new
weather wizard does like he causes Grant
Gustin to accidentally time travel I
have no idea who that's going to play
out but I love the idea of accidental
time travel they said that whenever they
do it it'll be both funny and really sad
which sounds like a perfect combination
to me question number 15 TARDIS guy asks
how big of an impact do you think the
Oliver's death on arrow will have on the
flash so so as of now Barry Allen has
absolutely no idea what happened to
Oliver the way they said on the scene
abhi fan talk the writer on the flash
said that they're kind of keeping their
storylines separate for now there will
be a new crossover in episode 18 ray
Palmer's going to go on the flash to get
some parts for his atom suit they
haven't said whether or not they're
they're going to openly acknowledged
Oliver's death on the flash in any of
the coming episodes but I think that
they will find out at a certain point if
not before
then definitely during that crossover
episode and that actually reminds me
because Ray Palmer is going to STAR Labs
to get gear for his atom suit it also
means he might get to shrink this season
if they're going to try and spin that
character off as his own show they atom
then they're probably gonna want to show
him doing as many awesome things as
possible just to get people excited no
confirmation on shrinking though like I
think they're going to hold that close
to their best thank you so much everyone
for so many questions these are always a
ton of fun to do and huge thank you to
all you guys that have been submitting
fan subs for my video so far here I
actually liked it a screencap video just
so you can see everyone that's done one
so far you guys have no idea how much
this has helped me so all of you
submitted fansubs totally earned a high
five the next time I see you guys at a
convention I will be its Star Wars
Celebration definitely comic-con maybe
wondercon so don't forget next week
arrow is midnight city is just like the
next part in the canary trilogy lots of
going down in the glades the flash
is going to be doing pipe piper and I
think he's actually supposed to be in a
couple episodes so his arc will actually
cross over multiple episodes so just in
case you guys haven't seen him yet you
can click here for my arrow episode 10
video and you can click here for my
flash episode 10 video thank you so much
for watching so I'll see you guys
tomorrow high fives
you